du rêve olympique sans doute pour
calgary en 2000 le 26 la ville devrait
selon toute probabilité annulé sa
candidature de demain dans un vote au
conseil municipal pascal comité lequel
recommandé au coeur de ceux du conflit
de la chicane
le montage financier le projet
nécessiterait 3 milliards de dollars en
fonds publics
le fédéral a offert 1 milliards 750
millions la condition que calgary et la
province fondée si l'autre partie donc
trop cher pour la ville de calgary qui
plafonnait son investissement à 700
millions mais s'était passé alors les
jeux olympiques le jeu en vaut-il la
chandelle ou comme vous l'avez lu le
flambeau olympique ans le professeur
expert en marketing du sport à l'école
des sciences de la gestion de l'uqam
vous connaissez c'est tellement bien
cette question là est ce que c'est le
bon choix à ce que calgary fait bien
détail le flambeau là maintenant mieux
vaut le faire maintenant que de laisser
les choses traîner le sport c'est un
levier un moyen pour générer des
retombées pour la population dans le
temps et à travers la société
ce n'est pas une fin en soi et
aujourd'hui ce que l'on constate que ce
soit avec la coupe du monde de soccer ou
les jeux olympiques il ya une surenchère
qui va organiser les jeux les plus
grandioses et l'histoire a montré que
malheureusement les retombées n'était
pas aussi extravagante que les
projections le mentionner et je pense
que les gens de calgary ont tout à fait
le droit de demander des comptes en fait
aux politiciens au cio parce que ces
gens là soient imputables il ya un coût
d'opportunité les milliards que l'on met
pour organiser de grands dieux jeux
olympiques pendant deux semaines sans
plan de reconversion sans plan
d'héritage socio-économique et bien sa
demande je pense un examen attentif de
la situation et des comptes aux gens
concernés que c'est une aventure
incroyable parce que même hathaway est
prêt à mettre 1 milliard 700 millions
c'est quand même beaucoup d'argent seul
en tout cas ottawa et et se prend à
vouloir mettre autant d'argent dans des
jeux olympiques
et encore les montants mentionnés sont
très modestes par rapport aux chiffres
des derniers jeux olympiques londres ça
coûtait plus de 30 milliards dollars
américains riou plus de 20 milliards
sotchi au delà de 50 milliards et les la
dernière coupe du monde de soccer plus
de 15 milliards de dollars américains
donc on ne sera pas dans les cinq six
milliards on va être bien au delà de
cela si on va de l'avant et le problème
c'est qu'il ya pas vraiment
le plan à savoir qu'est-ce qu'on fait
une fois les jeux olympiques terminés
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec les
infrastructures la reconversion
la construction de ces infrastructures
périphériques pour développer par
exemple le tournage logement social etc
comme par exemple la pologne l'a fait
pour le championnat d'europe des nations
de soccer en 2012 ou par exemple
singapour singapour à un grand prix de
formule 1 mais eux ont décidé
d'organiser ce circuit sur le réseau
routier de singapour et n'ont pas
construit quelque chose d' indépendants
comme à montréal que l'on utilise
seulement trois jours durant l'année une
offre de ta voix est peut-être destinée
à être jetée du point de vue du fait que
nos municipalités ont rarement le
milliard et demi à émettre là dedans il
alberta c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
période alors que les difficultés avec
les questions de pipelines et je
d'économies à faire ce genre
d'investissement la dont les
gouvernements les deux pays sont sages
c'est un risque et fait qu'ils faisaient
pas le compte
non le jeu n'en valait pas le flambeau
comme vous l'avait dit en début de
l'entrevue est un autre point important
c'est que derrière la candidature de
calgary a aussi des jeux de coulisses
pour permettre aux flames de calgary
d'avoir un nouvel amphithéâtre
la candidature de cas liés aux jeux
olympiques étaient un prétexte pour
construire un nouvel aréna et ainsi
faire plaisir à la fois l'équipe de
hockey la ligue nationale mais aussi à
gary bettman qui a été assez direct dans
ses menaces de déménagement advenant que
l'amphithéâtre actuelle elle avec la
bella vita on est belle n'était pas
remplacé par un plus belle
reina et les jeux olympiques étaient un
prétexte pour construire cet
amphithéâtre pour les flames donc on
n'en parle pas mais il est clair que
c'est un jeu de pouvoir pour avoir un
nouvel enfant j'ai entre deux autres
structures financières internationales
aussi on peut penser mais en même temps
le comité de calgary 2 me de 26 ans le
résumé que j'ai lus en tout cas prenez
les investissements au plaider en faveur
des avait des retombées de plusieurs
milliards de dollars pour la communauté
à l'appui d'études universitaires ou
écouter calgary a fait la même chose et
on les retombées ont été de moitié ce
qui avait été prévu
l'étude de que vous mentionnez a été
réalisée par une université qui
travaille étroitement avec le cio et qui
organise même des séminaires pour le
seyon grand intérêt je ferai attention à
l'indépendance de cette étude d'une part
et d'autre part il met de côté justement
les retombées associé aux
investissements périphériques
or si vous voulez justement laissé un
héritage socio économique il faut penser
à ces routes à ces logements sociaux
dont ils étaient là et on n'en parle pas
d'une part et d'autre part la question
des stades
moi ça m'horripile toujours quand on
regarde à court terme or vous savez un
stade au bout de dix ans il finit par
vous coûter le double de
l'investissement initial parce qu'il ya
l'entretien les rénovations les
réparations donc il faut de regarder la
durée de vie d'un projet no
l'amphithéâtre d'un aréna et pas
simplement l'avant on l'a jeux
olympiques ou coupe du monde de soccer
et la durée des jeux olympiques c'est
vraiment toute la durée donc ça c'est un
coup que doit assumer une collectivement
parce que le saddledome à 35 ans les
flames donc ont besoin de ce stade
l'alberta a été déjà une province
extrêmement riche mais même à se prendre
une bonne raison pour enclencher de la
préparation que je n'étais qu'un enjeu
est très direct aussi une équipe qui est
jeune entreprise privée des si je veux
avoir un amphithéâtre qui le
construisent eux-mêmes
ce n'est pas aux contribuables à être
pris en otage pour un amphithéâtre parce
que soi-disant l'actuel ne fait plus la
faire alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour l'en à l'avenir d'ee
à l'époque parce que plusieurs villes
pour que d'être candidate mais beaucoup
d'autres vont se poser les mêmes
questions parce que pas d'enrichissement
collectif vraisemblablement si je vous
en parle bien tout à travers des zones
est tout à fait parce qu'il ya pas
vraiment de vision intégrée ou
holistique si vous me permettez
l'expression
le seul pays qui essaie d'en avoir une
c'est la chine qui se sert par exemple
des jeux olympiques de beijing en 2022
pour par exemple développer la pratique
des sports d'hiver il vise 300 millions
de nouveaux pratiquants de sports
d'hiver en chine d'ici 2022
ils veulent également asseoir leur
réputation en tant que superpuissance
numéro un d'ici 2025 2030 en iran
indiquant dans c'est quoi l'amour
je donne cet exemple parce que la chine
joue la carte de ce qu'on appelle le ps
branding ou anciennement le diplomatie
branding en combinant judicieusement et
je termine là dessus le sport la
diplomatie internationale et le commerce
bien qu'ils volent sous le radar
contrairement au qatar ou la russie qui
dépensent beaucoup d'argent pour le
sport pour se mettre en valeur et
développer une image de marque forte
mais la chine est à surveiller parce
qu'il combine à la fois ses dimensions
sportives commerciales mais aussi
d'héritage socio économique pour leurs
populations
et ça pour moi c'est un exemple à suivre
pour les futures villes et pays candidat
d'organiser deux événements majeurs et
les moyens va se relâcher on a quand
même tout à fait ça viendrait aussi
justement passionnant avec plaisir merci
beaucoup